welcome to this video international
masks and never end okay never played
this guy who is this let me check
actually clicked on profile but don't
get the profile I disconnected here know
how they are Mourinho Ruiz okay so kind
of a strange connection here let's see
what we get an Enzo or something yep we
get the news oh and he's going for Queen
Sita we are going to play different line
year trying something new then 4 D 5
line that's interesting leading to
interesting play it's a very open open
position aggressive position which
should be 697 rook c8 this is something
that was played a couple of times not by
now by some strong players most notably
a Micky Adams and also a woman world
champion who you found they they both
had very good results with that black is
just developing very rapidly and going
to continue with Roxy aid rook c8 rook
takes d5 for quick piece play this is
how far I have seen it but I'm not
really knowing you the theory very much
ah the question is do I take now or not
once you three I mean okay okay I can
play Queen 85 actually Queen f5 but Roxy
one is kind of annoying
I can also take Queen chicks and pg5 494
this is very aggressive of course but
this is certainly in the spirit of this
on this line black going for a super
quick pspace counterplay we're going to
see how this leads but unfortunate is
that I can hardly ever play Queen a5
what really has before so I expect I
mean Quincy to probably not sure yeah
this is an alternative better here I'm
threatening night be three and this is
this is quite annoying tried annoying
this move yeah this one but here here
there are definite chances at tactics
night be three for example might be
three what is he going to play probably
queen before hmm yeah probably if that's
the only move Queen a five before Queen
takes a three takes on c5 Queen a five
check hmm 92 there is it that's
interesting but probably not not
entirely working and so before I is a
move that he might come up with I don't
I don't think i can make not be three
work and someone break we before it's
really really am putting an end to this
idea and queen bee six days before
hmm it looks it looks like i should have
some good move but i don't see one
really don't my development is really
good but it's not really clear what I
should do might be three Cuban before
quinby six as a move maybe yeah I have
to play move sometimes at some time I'm
not really satisfied with that but maybe
there wasn't wasn't anything better you
know preparing rugby three and sorry
night be three okay I can also take here
first but then I didn't know 93 what's
the what's the idea yeah after the Queen
trade I should be okay rook c 2 and so
on I was a bit more concerned about
other moskva before for example but ok
it's a it's the very interesting because
of whites bishop pair of course so maybe
have six tickling this a little bit
rooks it to a smooth but rook seat we go
see scott Bishop d3 so I came and I
don't want to take here so much [ __ ]
start with G for that all this very
little that's all very loose loose
looking but I have to use this momentum
that I have with the somewhat quicker
yeah if you want development
I'm a little bit more active here yes
just simply rook situ and getting the
pawn
you can play Bishop d3 hem and get them
get the e4 pawn but ok wants to go to f4
probably ok let's go here think about
this this later yeah he can take all
that night is six yeah Bishop now maybe
still here i can t can take the five
that is kind of annoying ok
yeah h-he and so on that's not really
that noise time morning not sure about
this position really so very very very
difficult to assess my pawn structure is
bad but the my looks are active not not
totally sure about it
94 this is the idea but he prevented
this okay I have some activity going for
a phone from my case rookie to maybe I'm
not sure and the d5 rook is kind of
annoying it might take care and play
rugby one does this could be a problem
hmm it probably is a problem yeah not
not really a move that I like to play
nice way to get the pawn going trying
and trying that be 5 and so on or maybe
get the king of King b6 and b5 now
usually kept like hingee 3 here I can
just do that I didn't Roxy Forbes the
king III yeah actually I could have
played King be three anyway but he
didn't but it didn't matter it's just
some bits so bad you mean the second
best news that the totally suffice and
the my night is dominated him
check check check check check check all
right come on black result haha i don't
know i think it was this should be good
actually here i have i've got such great
development I don't think I should be
worse in any way and he found all those
moves and around here I mean how can i
play that can probably wasn't in
terrible shape anyway but hmm kind of
undecided what I should do maybe I
should have just taken unknown 1c5 which
is of course possible check but I think
this should be fine really with all this
development computer wants to play
looxcie am ok but this this cannot be
really bad i mean really cannot G for
night edge form looks it too is more
precise ok but this is also not a
problem really Oh 97 I am totally
blundering stuff here I can just go 97
but she did not play he just went here
and I have to go look I ate this is
again again ok for like I guess
95 immediately maybe but yet if he could
have played 97 anyway yeah and this is
just not great yeah my pawn structure is
really bad I thought the activity but
it's uh yeah I cannot do much here I'm
kind of stuck here in this position I
have no idea this is the problem i
cannot push any of the pause during this
this is it's clear what happened i saw
that but what does my movie I don't have
a move really the Snider's is dominated
and I have no moves that was just bad
Jim and so maybe I have to improve
around here Luke c8 is the calm
suggestion or roxy ATM hmm what happens
after this that's very important hmm ok
this is very important I actually have
seen this idea before it's a very
important move Roxy aid yeah I know I
see it this is the point here and I can
do this move here computer just gives
this and this is a huge huge thing for
me because here I'm getting this Bishop
him so for example let's say he plays 90
Foreman going to take take and then I
get get the player on the light squares
the play that I want and need and this
is what happened to do ok I actually saw
and saw the idea once a couple of weeks
ago when I studied this with a student
but I forgot about it now I remember
that was a cute idea not see one ok this
is ok this is the move that gives black
ok play here in fact the way I played it
it's always a little bit a little bit
lesson
in Singh yeah okay it's not a problem
really but but still this is an improve
this is an improvement it would have
been much better to go for this night
see one business this is an improvement
quite a substantial one in comparison to
the game if he does that I'm better even
and after f3 which is the main move of
the of the engine can do this I'm sorry
of course bishop jakes and this kind of
thing which is equal to at the end it's
complicated but ok the real point was
the night see one ideas or something to
remember that some that makes all the
difference ok well thanks for watching